vamos a seguir trabajando con sistemas
de ecuaciones por eliminación sin
embargo en esta ocasión vamos a tener
que trabajar un poco nuestras ecuaciones
antes de que se eliminen las variables
es decir vamos a preparar a nuestras
ecuaciones antes de que se puedan
eliminar pero bueno vamos a escribir
nuestras ecuaciones en este caso voy a
jugar con 5x menos 10 y en esto igual a
15 y no voy a tomar otra ecuación la
ecuación 3x menos 2 james 3 x menos 2
james esto igual a 3 y lo primero que
quiero que te des cuenta es que hay
varias formas de resolver este tipo de
ecuaciones podemos resolverlo por
sustitución podríamos graficar lo y
resolver el sistema buscando el punto de
intersección sin embargo si yo quisiera
utilizar el método de suma y resta
entonces lo que hay que hacer es sumarle
o restarle una ecuación lo mismo de
ambos lados y bueno en el vídeo pasado
lo que hacíamos era tomarme la parte
izquierda de estas dos ecuaciones
sumarlas y después tomarme la parte
derecha de estas ecuaciones y también
sumarlas sin embargo si te das cuenta si
yo sumo el resto
estas dos ecuaciones no voy a poder
eliminar
una de estas variables mi resultado va a
quedar tanto en términos de x como en
términos de entonces qué podemos hacer y
bueno las respuestas que vamos a
multiplicar una o ambas ecuaciones por
una constante de tal manera que después
de hacer esto se puedan cancelar por
eliminación y bueno lo primero que debes
hacer es elegir una variable para
cancelarla así que vamos a decir que
quiero eliminar al ayer para eliminar el
aiem date cuenta que aquí tenemos 10 y
abajo tenemos 2 james así que déjenme
primero copiar la ecuación que tenemos
arriba 5 x menos 10 igual a 15 y ahora
fíjate en esta ecuación de aquí abajo si
lo multiplicamos por alguna constante y
bueno hay que saber qué constante habrá
alguna forma que cuando nosotros
multiplicamos por esta constante y la
sumamos a esta ecuación que tenemos de
amarillo se pueda eliminar la variable
james y bueno la respuesta es que sí
porque fíjate aquí tengo un 2 bien de
hecho tengo menos 2 james para que se
cancele tendría que ser 10 positivo
porque date cuenta que en la ecuación de
amarillo tenemos un -10 james entonces
para que se cancele abajo
hay que quedar 10 positivo y para que la
ecuación de abajo se convierta en un 10
de positivo hay que multiplicarlo por
menos 5 y ojo vamos a multiplicar toda
la ecuación tanto el lado izquierdo como
el lado derecho para que así no se
altere la ecuación no se altere la
igualdad así que vamos a hacerlo menos 5
x 3 x es menos 15 x menos 15 x después
nos queda menos x menos más es justo lo
que queríamos 5 x 2 10 10 james es justo
lo que queríamos y al final me queda 3 x
menos 5 lo cual es menos 15 y está
perfecto porque ahora ya tenemos menos
10 + dj y si nosotros sumamos estas dos
ecuaciones entonces se va a cancelar
todo lo que tiene que ver con que justo
esa era la idea para nosotros utilizar
el método de suma y resta o el método de
eliminación es decir lo que queríamos
era cancelar una de estas variables y si
sumamos estas dos ecuaciones se va a
cancelar todo lo que tiene que ver con
james y que me quedaría 5 x menos 15 x
pues esto es lo mismo que menos 10 x no
olvides que aquí teníamos un menos y por
lo tanto 5
15 10 10 x menos 10 más 10 justo era lo
que queríamos que se cancelarán entonces
estas dos se van se hacen 0 y entonces
solamente me queda menos 10 x del lado
izquierdo de esta ecuación mientras que
del lado derecho me queda 15 menos 15 lo
cual es 0 y bueno si de aquí queremos
despejar la x lo que voy a hacer es
dividir ambos lados de la ecuación entre
menos 10 me va a quedar que x es igual a
cero entre menos 10 pero sea entre menos
10 es 0 y date cuenta como ya habíamos
encontrado una ecuación con solamente
una incógnita y con esto logramos
encontrar la x el valor de x x igual a 0
y una vez que ya tengo este valor de x
lo que voy a hacer es sustituirlo en la
primera ecuación para encontrar el valor
de james y me queda 5 x 0 se van y
entonces me queda que menos 10 james es
igual a 15 ya sé que x vale 0 y entonces
divido a ambos lados entre menos 10 voy
a obtener valor de james estos dos se
van queda que james es igual a 15 entre
menos 10 lo cual es menos tres medios
- tres medios y perfecto ya tengo el
valor para xy para que solucionaran esta
ecuación x igual a 0 y la menos 3 medios
o dicho de otra manera el punto cero con
menos tres medios es el punto de
intersección de estas dos rectas o son
los valores de la solución de estas dos
ecuaciones y bueno pues vamos a ver si
también cumple la segunda ecuación así
que vamos a sustituir tres por cero
menos dos por qué pero lleva de menos
tres medios menos dos por menos tres
medios esto tiene que ser igual a 3 3
por 0 0 - por menos me da más y estos
dos se van y solamente me queda 30 más 3
estrés y perfecto la comprobación de la
segunda ecuación si quedan y muy bien ya
con esto tenemos la comprobación ahora
lo que quiero hacer es resolver otro
problema que tenga que ver igual con la
eliminación o con suma y resta pero que
no sea directa que tengamos que
multiplicar por alguna constante para
que entonces podamos resolver el sistema
así que pues déjame poner otro par de
ecuaciones y no voy a tomar las
siguientes ecuaciones 5 x + 7 james
igual a 15 y después voy a poner aquí
abajo con otro color
- 3 james esto lo voy a ser igual a 5 y
quiero resolver este sistema de
ecuaciones ahora date cuenta que si lo
vamos a resolver por eliminación
no podemos sumar las ecuaciones de una
manera inmediata porque entonces nos
eliminaría ninguna de las dos variables
y entonces es cuando se me ocurre
multiplicar por una constante ya sea la
ecuación de arriba o ya sea la ecuación
de abajo o ambas y de hecho si te das
cuenta en esta ocasión tenemos que
multiplicar ambas pero antes de eso
recuerda que lo que tenemos que hacer es
elegir una de las dos variables para
cancelar en este caso la yes negativa
que sería mucho más fácil cancelarla sin
embargo vamos a trabajar con la equis
para hacerlo mucho más divertido así que
quiero cancelar la equis y para cancelar
la equis podría multiplicar cualquiera
de estas dos ecuaciones por una fracción
de tal manera que al volver la negativa
se cancela da con este 7x o con este 5x
sin embargo para no trabajar con
fracciones lo cual no va a ser nada
grato lo que voy a hacer es buscar el
mínimo común múltiplo entre 5 y 7 para
que así pueda ir guiando a ambas
ecuaciones a ese mínimo común múltiplo
que por cierto es 35 y bueno si yo lo
que quiero
35 x 35 tenemos que multiplicar la
ecuación de arriba por 7 para que me
quede 7 por 5 35 x y la de abajo por 5
pero por 5 negativo de tal manera que al
multiplicar menos 5 por 7 me quede menos
35 x y ya con esto voy a poder eliminar
la variable x y entonces voy a lograr
tener una ecuación con solamente una
incógnita y muy fácil de resolver si lo
hago por el método de eliminación ojo
esto es muy común cuando utilizas el
método suma y resta cruzan los
coeficientes para que así se puede
eliminar una variable así que pues vamos
a hacerlo si multiplicó la ecuación de
arriba por 7 que me va a quedar 7 por 5
pues es 35 35 x entonces vamos a notarlo
35 x y después nos queda 7 x 7 7 por 7
es 49 49 y y por último queda 7 por 15 7
por 15
es lo mismo que 70 más 35 que es 105 ojo
recuerda que hay que multiplicar toda la
ecuación por 7 tanto el lado izquierdo
de la igualdad como el lado derecho es
la igualdad y bueno pues vamos a hacer
lo mismo para la ecuación de abajo
voy a multiplicar la x menos
tanto del lado izquierdo como del lado
derecho y que me va a quedar menos 57 x
35 x menos x menos me da más 5 x 39 15
15 más 15 m y del otro lado me queda 5 x
menos 55 x menos 5 es menos 25 y ahora
sí date cuenta que ya tenemos el mismo
coeficiente al lado de la equis y no
sólo eso 1 es positivo y el otro es
negativo por lo tanto cuando yo sume
estas dos ecuaciones se va a eliminar
todo lo que tiene que ver con x que es
justo lo que queríamos para resolver
esta ecuación por el método de suma y
resta así que vamos a sumar estas dos
ecuaciones de tal manera que se elimine
todo lo que tenga que ver con x y dice
35 x menos 35 x se van 49 y más 15 james
esto es lo mismo que 54 más 10 64 y 64 y
james esto es igual a 105 menos 25 550
100 menos 20 es 80 y aquí ya tengo una
ecuación con solamente una incógnita muy
fácil de resolver si divido ambos lados
entre 64 me queda que james es igual a
83 64 64 y 64 1
solamente me queda del otro lado 80
entre 64 que por cierto le podemos sacar
octava tanto arriba como abajo si yo
divido 80 entre 8 me va a dar 10 y 64
entre 8 y 8 por lo tanto no quedaría 10
sobre 8 10 sobre 8 que por cierto ambos
tienen mitad entonces esto es lo mismo
que cinco cuartos ya tengo el valor de
james el valor de ya que resuelve ambas
ecuaciones simultáneamente es igual a
cinco cuartos pero ojo no olvidemos que
no he acabado el problema ya tengo el
valor de jets sin embargo todavía no
tengo el valor de x así que para sacar a
x tengo que elegir una de estas dos
ecuaciones y vamos a elegir la segunda
ecuación así que vamos a sustituir el
valor de james me queda 7 x menos 3
james esto es igual a 5 pero en lugar de
james voy a poner el valor de james
llevarles cinco cuartos por lo tanto voy
a sustituir ayer por cinco cuartos que
es mi solución en esta ecuación y me
queda 7 x menos tres por cinco cuartos
esto es igual a 57 x menos 15 cuartos
esto es igual a 5 no esperen esperen
esperen que estoy haciendo adquieres
borrar de nuevo
todo esto porque aquí me suena que algo
está mal dice tres por cuatro no no no
no esperen si estoy bien si estoy bien
aunque estoy haciendo es 3 por 5 15
entre 4 y 15 cuartos esto es igual a 57
x menos 15 cuartos es igual a 5 y ahora
sí voy a sumar 15 cuartos de ambos lados
de la ecuación entonces más 15 cuartos
más 15 cuartos del lado izquierdo estos
dos se cancelan y solamente me quedan 7
x 15 cuartos y menos 15 cuartos se van y
del lado derecho me queda 5 más 15
cuartos pero 5 es lo mismo que 20
cuartos entonces lo voy a escribir como
20 cuartos más 15 cuartos y 20 cuartos
más 15 cuartos déjenme bajar un poco la
pantalla esto es lo mismo que 35 cuartos
entonces 7 x es igual a 35 cuartos y
ahora voy a multiplicar todo por un
séptimo o de otra manera voy a dividir
todo entre 7 entonces vamos a dividir
esta parte entre 7 o lo que es lo mismo
multiplicado por un séptimo y de tal
manera que estos dos se van y solamente
me queda x mientras que el lado derecho
de 35 se puede dividir entre 75
y entonces solamente me queda cinco
cuartos x es igual a cinco cuartos y es
igual a cinco cuartos guau los dos
valores son los mismos es decir que la
solución de este sistema de ecuaciones
es x igual a cinco cuartos y es igual a
cinco cuartos o dicho otra manera la
intersección de estas dos rectas es el
punto 545 cuartos y bueno vamos a
achicar oa comprobar en la primera
actuación que realmente si llegamos al
resultado correcto dice cinco por equis
pero x vale cinco cuartos cinco por
cinco cuartos más siete porque pero
lleva a los cinco cuartos más siete por
cinco cuartos esto tiene que ser igual a
15 vamos a ver si cinco por cinco
cuartos en lo mismo que 25 cuartos 7 por
5 35 entonces me queda 35 cuartos y 25
cuartos más 35 cuartos es lo mismo que
60 cuartos lo cual es 15 perfecto que es
justo lo que queríamos acabamos de
comprobar en la primera ecuación y bueno
tú puedes verificar en la ecuación de
abajo sin embargo no es tan necesario
porque justo de aquí salió que x vale 5
cuartos así que nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo